the international pizza expo is taking
place this week and one of the big
events is the best of the best bake off
and joining us now i'm so excited
celebrity chef donatella arpaia who is
one of the judges welcome to the show
thank you it's so great to be here it is
great to have you here so you've got
your own restaurant you're a star of the
food network yes
yes i'm a head i'm a head of iron chef
america an exxon chef and i'm considered
tough but fair that's what i like about
you
when you judge pizza what do you look
for
i mean pizza is an art and a science
there's so much to it there's so much
technique and artistry the crust the
quality of the ingredients and then
creativity so yesterday i did a demo
live at the pizza expo i love it were
you there no but anytime you do a demo i
love it and we're gonna do one today
okay so here you go i'm gonna make you
do something this is my pizza
amatrichana with roasted cherry tomatoes
do you like spicy there's don't touch
that it's hot calabrian chili and then
put a little shaving this is very i made
it very easy for you thank you you know
me well shaving of parmesan
cheese and we used thin sliced
mozzarella
and the quality of ingredients fresh
roasted tomatoes red onion bacon i mean
spice what more do you want you've got
everything it's a favorite at my
restaurant provo pizza bar in new york
and that is a key fresh ingredients
right
quality
and now because we are in vegas baby yes
and one in vegas um i am making a
dessert pizza so this was my dessert
pizza it is just regular pizza dough
look at your eyes i am
sugar and we're using mascarpone cheese
which is famous for tiramisu but mar i
i'm known as the meatball queen because
i want meatball madness and i'm also
known as the cheese queen yes and
because i love
cheese because i grew up spending my
summers in italy so this is mars whipped
marshma bone cream
laid on top of hazelnut spread which you
know there's a brand name for it but i
don't know if we're allowed to say it
you can say it but nutella i mean it's
nutella we got cream and we got cheese
and i got about 45 seconds today
marshmallow marshmallows blow torch
did you hear that we have the blowtorch
here comes hector your assistant with
the blow torch oh look are you
we don't want to light up your hair on
fire no that's right i'm going to stand
over here so hector has the blowtorch
what a way to make a pizza look at this
come on heck hector's lightning
blow torch we see it we see it melting
oh
and this is just this is the blowtorch
you bought at home depot right yeah i
don't like the little little guys you
know those creme brulee tortures no you
go big yeah you go bigger you go home i
know it's it's it's dripping a little
bit that's okay chef donald tell it all
right i i think everyone here is gonna
eat it
are you kidding me we're gonna we're
gonna start with this and we're gonna
finish with this now the international
pizza expo is happening right now yes
and i'm judging the best of the best
tomorrow um and like i said i'm fair
follow me on donatello arpaio and i'm
going to judge the best of the best i
love it such an honor to have you here
in the kitchen we're going to eat this
in las vegas now we'll be right back